Hey there Shankar here. Last week, our friends at the Public Radio Program 1A produced a discussion about rights of passage. As part of that episode, they asked me to deliver an on-air commencement address to graduates finishing their studies this year. We thought we'd bring you those remarks and offer our warm congratulations to all students, parents, and caregivers who are marking this moment. Greetings to the Class of 2020, to the faculty, parents, grandparents, and friends joining us today. Congratulations. It's a great honor to be with you in this most extraordinary of moments for this most unusual of commencement ceremonies. Now, extraordinary and unusual may not be the first words that come to mind. Perhaps the words you would
大家好，我是香卡。上周，我们的公共广播节目1A的朋友们制作了一期关于人生转折点的讨论。作为该节目的一部分，他们邀请我向今年完成学业的毕业生发表一次空中毕业典礼演讲。我们觉得应该把这些话带给大家，并向所有在这个时刻庆祝的学生、父母和照顾者致以我们热烈的祝贺。向2020届毕业生，以及今天加入我们的教职员工、父母、祖父母和朋友们问好。恭喜你们。在这个最不寻常的毕业典礼上，在如此非凡的时刻与大家在一起，我感到非常荣幸。现在，非凡和不寻常可能不是首先浮现在脑海的词。也许你们会
choose are more colorful. Go ahead, shout those words out loud. It's okay to feel grief that your commencement isn't how you imagined it. You've worked hard to get to this moment. You deserve to be wearing your cap and gown, to walk across the stage, shake hands with your deans and professors, and collect your diploma. Your family is deserved to bear witness to this moment, to know that all their years of hard work and sacrifice were worth it. Giving up this right of passage is very hard, and it comes at a time when many others are going through much worse. Some of you might be feeling guilty about being sad. You
选择的词会更丰富多彩。来吧，大声喊出那些词。为你的毕业典礼不像你想象的那样而感到悲伤是没有关系的。为了走到这一刻，你付出了努力。你应该穿上学位服，走过舞台，与你的院长和教授握手，并领取你的毕业证。你的家人理应见证这一时刻，知道他们多年来的辛勤工作和牺牲是值得的。放弃这个人生转折点是非常艰难的，而且它发生在一个许多其他人正在经历更糟糕事情的时刻。你们中的有些人可能会为感到悲伤而感到内疚。你们
might be thinking of all the lives that have been lost to the COVID-19 pandemic, to the millions of people out of work. And you might think, I really shouldn't be sad about losing out on a graduation ceremony. It's good that you're paying attention to all those out there who are hurting, but that shouldn't mean your pain doesn't count. Suffering isn't a zero-sum game. Your pain doesn't go away because someone else's pain is greater. Your sadness about missing out on graduation ceremonies
可能会想到因2019冠状病毒病疫情而失去生命的所有人，以及数百万失业的人。你可能会想，我真的不应该为失去毕业典礼而感到难过。你能关注到所有那些正在痛苦的人是很好的，但这并不意味着你的痛苦就不重要。苦难不是一场零和游戏。你的痛苦不会因为别人的痛苦更大而消失。你对错过毕业典礼的悲伤
is very likely coupled with anxieties. Will you be able to find a job? If you find one, will it make you happy? Are you ever going to pay off your student loans? As you think about these big, difficult questions, I'd like to tell you a story that shows why moments like this, moments of chaos and disruption, allow us to discover things about ourselves. The story I'd like to share is of a young woman in Maya Shankar. When Maya was a girl, her mother gave her a violin. She was captivated by the instrument and she began playing constantly.
很可能伴随着焦虑。你能找到工作吗？如果你找到了，它会让你快乐吗？你还能还清学生贷款吗？当你们思考这些宏大而艰难的问题时，我想给你们讲一个故事，它展示了为什么像这样的时刻——混乱和颠覆的时刻——能让我们发现关于我们自身的某些东西。我想分享的故事是关于玛雅·香卡这位年轻女性的。当玛雅还是个小女孩时，她的母亲给了她一把小提琴。她被这件乐器迷住了，并开始不停地练习。
Eventually she was accepted to Juilliard, the renowned music school in New York City. She became a student of the great violinist, Itsak Perlman. She was well on her way to becoming a professional musician. Everything was going exactly to plan. And then one day, as she was practicing, she overstretched a finger and felt a pop. She had injured a tendon. Months passed. Her hand never healed properly, and eventually doctors told her she had to give up the violin.
最终她被纽约著名的音乐学校茱莉亚学院录取。她成了伟大的小提琴家伊扎克·帕尔曼的学生。她正迈向成为一名专业音乐家的道路。一切都完全按计划进行着。然后有一天，当她在练习时，她过度伸展了一根手指，并听到了一声脆响。她拉伤了肌腱。几个月过去了。她的手再也没有完全康复，最终医生告诉她必须放弃小提琴。
The grief that Maya felt was enormous. Her plan for her life, her very identity, had been wrapped around music. She didn't know what to do next. And then one day, as she was helping her parents clean out their basement, she stumbled on one of her sister's course books. It was The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker. And as she read the book, Maya found herself captivated by the human mind. She realized she wanted to learn more about the brain and how it works, and so she decided to study cognitive science. Fast forward a couple of decades, and Maya
玛雅感受到的悲伤是巨大的。她的人生计划，甚至她的身份，都与音乐紧紧缠绕在一起。她不知道接下来该怎么办。然后有一天，当她帮父母清理地下室时，她偶然发现了她姐姐的一本教材。那是斯蒂芬·平克的《语言本能》。当她读这本书时，玛雅发现自己被人类的心智迷住了。她意识到她想更多地了解大脑及其运作方式，于是她决定学习认知科学。快进几十年，玛雅
has since completed a Rhodes Scholarship, and a stint in the Obama White House. I tell you Maya's story not to suggest it should be your story, but because it shows that when the world is uncertain and the ground under our feet feels unsteady, that's often the time we discover new things about ourselves. Periods of disruption invariably lead to invention and reinvention. A number of years ago, there was a transit strike in London. Many subway stations were closed. People had to find a new way to get around. It was stressful.
此后完成了罗德奖学金项目，并在奥巴马白宫工作过一段时间。我讲玛雅的故事并不是建议它应该成为你的故事，而是因为它表明，当世界充满不确定性、我们脚下的土地感到不稳定时，往往是我们发现关于自己的新事物的时刻。动荡时期总是会导致发明和再发明。多年前，伦敦发生了一场公交罢工。许多地铁站关闭了。人们不得不寻找一种出行的新方式。这令人压力山大。
It was annoying. Once the strike was done, you might expect everyone quickly went back to their old commutes. But that didn't happen. When researchers looked at the data, they found that thousands of people stuck with new routines that they had invented during the strike. The chaos had helped many Londoners identify new and better ways of moving about the world. You can see where I'm going with this. Like those London commuters, you are grappling with a change to the normal rhythms and routines of
这很烦人。一旦罢工结束，你可能会期望每个人都迅速回到他们旧的通勤方式。但并没有发生。当研究人员查看数据时，他们发现成千上万的人坚持了他们在罢工期间发明的新日常。这种混乱帮助许多伦敦人找到了在世界各地移动的新方法和更好的方法。你可以看出我要表达的意思。就像那些伦敦通勤者一样，你正在努力应对生活中正常节奏和日常的改变。
life. Like Maya Shankar, you have suddenly seen your plans upended. The way forward is unclear. But what lies before you is an opportunity to look at the world with fresh eyes. I'm often reminded of this when I travel to a new city. I'm peering around, looking with fascination at the buildings, the parks. Meanwhile, all around me, the people who actually live in that city are hurrying about, barely looking up, not stopping to notice the sites around them. When chaos strikes, we all become tourists in our own lives. We start to see with fresh eyes, and when we do, we realize the world really does have endless possibilities. In fact, this is why we have rights of passage like graduation ceremonies. They are designed to give us a chance to stop, to take stock,
就像玛雅·香卡一样，你突然发现你的计划被颠覆了。前进的道路尚不明确。但摆在你面前的是一个以全新视角审视世界的机会。当我到一个新城市旅行时，我经常被提醒这一点。我四处张望，充满着迷地看着建筑物、公园。与此同时，我周围所有真正住在那个城市的人都在匆忙赶路，几乎不抬头，没有停下来注意他们周围的景点。当混乱来临时，我们都成了自己生活中的游客。我们开始用新鲜的眼光看待事物，当我们这样做时，我们意识到世界确实有无限的可能性。事实上，这就是我们举办诸如毕业典礼之类的人生转折点的原因。它们旨在给我们一个停下来、审视现状的机会，
to look back and say, look how far I've come, to look forward and ask, where do I want to go from here? You might not get the ceremony, but you can take a moment to stop and do those things anyway. Celebrate your accomplishments and ask how you fit into a changed world. Congratulations and good luck! This bonus episode was produced by Tara Boyer.
回顾过去并说，看我走得有多远，展望未来并问，从这里我想去哪里？你可能没有那个典礼，但你仍然可以花时间停下来做那些事情。庆祝你的成就，并问问自己如何融入一个改变了的世界。恭喜你们，祝你们好运！这集特别节目由塔拉·博耶制作。
If there's someone in your life who might enjoy it, please share it with them. If your friend is new to podcasting, please help them subscribe to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你的生活中有人会喜欢它，请与他们分享。如果你的朋友是播客新手，请帮他们订阅《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台。你这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。